schwierige krisendiplomatie und einer
der sich in dieser woche in die
diskussion mit eingeschaltet hat ist der
spd fraktionsvorsitzende rolf mützenich
erst mir jetzt zugeschaltet aus köln
schönen guten abend herr mützenich
herr mützenich sie haben sich in den
vergangenen tagen immer wieder für eine
friedliche lösung und vor allem für das
primat der diplomatie eingesetzt jetzt
muss man sagen wenn man auf die
vergangene woche schaut das ergebnis der
ganzen diplomatischen bemühungen ist
dass es noch mehr russische truppen an
der grenze gibt als zuvor müssen sie
nicht feststellen mit der diplomatie so
wie sie jetzt betrieben wird ist putin
nicht beizukommen
und ich bin ja nicht der einzige der
sich für diplomatie ausgesprochen hat
das haben eigentlich alle getan der
deutsche regierungschef aber auch der
amerikanische präsident selbst wenn er
vor möglicherweise einer militärischen
intervention
warnt ist er weiterhin auf diplomatie
eingestellt und am mittwoch wollen sich
ja zumindest nach dem jetzigen zeitplan
auch der amerikanische und russische
außenminister treffen es ist wichtig
dass wir jede minute jede stunde nutzen
damit es nicht tatsächlich zu einem
krieg kommt diplomatie nutzte vor allem
dann etwas wenn sie zu etwas führt ein
kluger kollege vom deutschlandfunk hat
das was momentan passiert diplomatie im
leerlauf genannt wir haben es gestern
gesehen in umkämpften gebiet in der
ukraine gibt es gab es gestern allein
2000 gezählte explosionen es gab zwei
tote auf ukrainischer seite wo ist denn
die rote linie ab der mann dann doch zu
sanktionen greifen muss nun es geht
jetzt insbesondere darum gerade auch im
osten der ukraine zu humanitären
maßnahmen zukommen korridore zu öffnen
die menschen zu erreichen und vielleicht
sogar das was olaf scholz mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten
erreicht hat nämlich auf der einen seite
gesetzentwürfe der osze über antworten
und vielleicht auch zu einem
gefangenenaustausch zu kommen das hat
jetzt eine wichtige funktion
ob das hilft glaube ich wird niemand
hier heute vorhersagen können aber wir
müssen wir müssen alles unterlassen was
dazu führt dass diese kriegs dynamik
noch weiter angetrieben wird der
eindruck die jetzt momentan entsteht ist
dass putin ein neue kriegsführung ausübt
und dass der westen mit alten
diplomatischen mitteln darauf reagiert
die bisher nicht viel ausrichten konnten
muss man da die strategie nicht anpassen
nun wir passen die strategie an auf der
einen seite die deutlichen warnungen
auch die aufklärungen die wir haben die
wir ja nicht zurückhalten sondern
öffentlich machen auf der anderen seite
weiß putin welchen preis er wird
bezahlen müssen aber der größte preis
ist den die menschen zu bezahlen haben
und uns mitten hinein wenn ich sie da
unterbrechen darf das ist ja das problem
dass das ist richtig und wir müssen
einfach sehen dass wir trotzdem leben
und ich erhoffe mir von weiteren
gesprächen doch noch etwas das wir eben
dazu kommen dass es zu verabredungen
kommen die nato die amerikanische seite
haben ja auch vorschläge unterbreitet
worüber sollte man reden wenn nicht
darüber auch am mittwoch zwischen den
beiden außenministern alles das sind
wichtige dinge und wir dürfen keine
chance unterlassen um den menschen die
ja nun mal in den gebieten sind und wenn
es insbesondere dann auch noch zu
weiteren verwerfungen militärischer
seitz kommt auch von den rebellen dort
gegen zu arbeiten der
bundesfinanzminister hat gerade die
befürchtung geäußert dass es schwere
auswirkungen auch auf die deutsche
wirtschaft geben könnte wenn russland in
reaktion auf westliche sanktionen die
gas lieferungen einstellen könnte ist
die deutsche bundesregierung auch
deshalb so zögerlich und zurückhaltend
bei sanktionen weil sie eben auf die
auswirkungen für die deutsche wirtschaft
schaut man muss es natürlich mit
bedenken aber insbesondere was den
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher und
droht ich meinen wir werden nicht nur
mit relativ leeren gasspeichern
konfrontiert sondern dann wahrscheinlich
auch mit einer beeinträchtigung der
gaslieferungen aus russland wir haben
alternativen die europäische union hat
lieferungen auch zugesichert aber alles
das wollen wir ja verhindern es geht ja
nicht alleine nur um wirtschaftliche
aktivitäten sondern es geht ganz konkret
auch um unser leben hier in deutschland
letzte frage mit bitte um eine kurze
antwort vor dem lsg hat gestern in
münchen eine klare und ehrliche antwort
auf die frage gefordert ob er auf sein
land in die nato beitreten können oder
nicht welche antwort können sie ihm
geben nun steht zur zeit die ich auf der
tagesordnung darin sind sich alle eben
auch einig sowohl innerhalb der nato als
auch das was bisher besprochen worden
ist und selbst upd ukraine weiß das
haben wir ja auch bei dem besuch von
olaf scholz erlebt dass das nicht das
dringlichste zurzeit ist sondern dass es
zurzeit darum geht die kriegs dynamik
wieder zurück zu drehen das was der
amerikanische präsident biden gesagt hat
die temperatur zu senken
rolf mützenich spd fraktionsvorsitzende
im bundestag herzlichen dank für das
gespräch danke für die einladung